para interrumpir el desierto agroalimentario
y comenzar a corregir el sistema alimenticio disfuncional
que hemos creado.
Tal vez parezca una muy pequeña contramedida
para un grave, enorme problema - solo se trata de plantar flores -
pero si las abejas tienen acceso a buena nutrición,
nosotros también tendremos buena nutrición
gracias a sus servicios de polinización.
Y cuando las abejas tienen acceso a buena nutrición,
son más capaces de utilizar sus propias defensas naturales,
su sistema de salud,
en el que han confiado durante millones de años.
Así que la belleza de ayudar a las abejas de esta manera, para mí,
es que cada uno de nosotros se comporte
un poco más como una sociedad de abejas, una sociedad de insectos,
donde cada una de nuestras acciones individuales
pueda contribuir a una solución magnífica,
una propiedad emergente,
que es mucho mayor que la simple suma
de nuestras acciones individuales.
Hagan que el pequeño acto de plantar flores
y mantenerlas libres de pesticidas,
sea el motor de un cambio a gran escala.
En nombre de las abejas, gracias.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Gracias. Sólo una pregunta rápida.
Los últimos números de la mortandad de las abejas,
¿hay alguna señal de que las cosas estén tocando fondo?
¿Cuál es tu nivel de esperanza o depresión en esto?
Maria Spivak: Sí.
Por lo menos en los Estados Unidos
un promedio del 30 % de todas las colmenas de abejas
se pierden todos los inviernos.
Hace unos 20 años,
estábamos en una pérdida de 15 %.
Así que cada vez es más precaria.
CA: No es el 30 % anual. MS: Sí, 30 % anual.
CA: 30 % anual. MS: Pero los apicultores pueden
dividir sus colonias y pueden mantener el mismo número,
pueden recuperar algunas de sus pérdidas.
Estamos en un punto de inflexión.
No podemos darnos el lujo de perder mucho más.
Tenemos que estar muy agradecidos
de todos los apicultores que hay. Planten flores.
CA: Gracias.
(Aplausos)